прилетів Дрон і жінка медик яка
спасала загинула Оля 200 Я
заїхав більше 20 000 це величезні
цифри в такій кількості ми не отримували
таких навантажень з 14го
року обласна лікарня Мечникова у Дніпрі
6 вечора Зазвичай саме в цей час до
приймального відділення найактивніше
прибувають карети швидкої з прифронтових
зон
Запоріжжя коли було два часа назад
зазвичай 90% пацієнтів тут евакуйовані
поранені військові лише за цей день вже
понад два десятки з Донеччини та
Запоріжжя виїхали в кабіночку
раздват Андрієві 39 вдома чекає дружина
та двоє дітей він піхотинець ЗСУ чоловік
терміново вивезли З торського що на
Донеччині під час мінометного обстрілу
чоловіка зачепили
уламки
точки взагалі ми мали піти від точки А
поки доходили нас підстрелили вибух був
уламки потрапили ноги руки живіт я
більше постраждав я врятував
побратима доки Андрія везуть по коридору
лікарі нам пояснюють поспілкуватися з
пораненими пацієнтами буде непросто бо у
свідомості їх сюди привозять
зрідка наша лікарня приймає найважчих це
десятки поранених які надходять кожного
дня і кожноне іноч виглядають
нейрохірург хірург травматолог чи
потребує пацієнт оперативного негайного
втручання
щосьли на огляди первинну допомогу для
пораненого від кількох хвилин до
півгодини У кожного з них є свій номер
який записують на руці або клаптику
простирадла це для обліку який за час
повномасштабної війни вже налічує понад
20 000 більше 20 000 тільки за останні
600 днів Це величезні цифри до нас
поступило більше 2 000 хлопців які
втратили кінцівки виконується до 100
операцій кожного дня щоб врятувати життя
воїну всі
реанімаційні відділення
заповнені на етапах евакуації до 100
пункту дуже багато часу проходить і тому
гинуть м'язи на нижній кінцівці або на
верхній де було накладений турнікет і на
жаль потім для того щоби спасти йому
життя потрібно ампутувати на
[музика]
Віталію який зараз на операційному столі
вже ампутували половину ноги у
Запорізькій лікарні втім через велике
навантаження ресурсів доглядати його
далі там немає до того ж почалися
ускладнення чоловіка доправили сюди у
тяжкому стані саме мінновибухові травми
найчастіше зустрічаються серед поранених
і робота з ними найскладніший досвід і
для самих
лікарів
найважче бачити ці всі травми дуже
багато ампутацій дуже багато молодих
хлопців які вже інваліди йдуть з
2325тирічного Віку Ну і реально не
вихватає часу Ну палати набитя
військовими в цих не не вспіваєш
проперувати в один день треба брати всіх
і вся у цих стінах зізнаються працівники
лікарні їм доводиться надавати ще й
основну психологічну підтримку для
бійців щодня обов'язково треба
підтримувати вони ж нас захищають
молодці сначала підірвався нога потом
Дрон
добивав а потім уже коли
їхали в машині евакуації настаний пункт
прилетів Дрон
і жінка медик яка була спасала загинула
і через кришу прилетів дрон і дірку в
споні зробив Таку як і
сковорідочку і в Уля 200 Я заїхав після
операції на найтяжчих поранених чекає
перша ніч У реанімації на ранок огляд
ран і перша
перев'язка йому
боляче біля трьх-чотирьох діб Вони
знаходяться у реанімаційному відділенні
до стабілізації стану до покращення
лабораторних показників потім ми
намагаємося переводити в профільні
відділення в нас був тоді дуже складний
період коли з травня місяця вони
надходили по серпень Ну потім ну в
такому в такій кількості ми не
отримували таких навантажень з 14-го
року саме через рекордне навантаження за
кількістю поранених серед яких і
цивільні з прифронтових містечок і сіл
лікарня Мечникова не в змо лишати тут
пацієнтів до повного А часом навіть і
часткового одужання їх усіх переводять
до лікарень інших міст
України сьогодні з лікарні Мечникова до
Києва евакуаційний бус везе п'ятеро
важких поранених та кілька стабільних
військових іноземців для підтримання
стану пацієнтів тут обладнана мобільна
реанімація зокрема і система штучної
вентиляції
легень на підключення пацієнтів до
систему парамедиків півгодини зволікати
не можна ці фахівці іноземці керівник
команди німець Макс він уже понад
півроку евакуює військових між містами
України і навчає цього українських
парамедиків ця робота - це абсолютно не
те що у нас в Німеччині у нас немає
таких пацієнтів поранених військових ми
маємо бути готові Раптом щось станеться
в дорозі у нас для цього є обладнання
досвідчений лікар в Україні не багато
спеціалістів які мають необхідну
підготовку і обладнання для перевезення
таких пацієнтів тож ми почали
спеціальний навчальний курс тут у Дніпрі
для українських медиків щоб навчити їх
транспортувати
поранених іноземні партнери значною
мірою допомагають лікарні Мечникова аби
заклад міг безперервно приймати
поранених це і сучасне реанімаційне
обладнання і медикаменти однак потреби
постійно
зростають зараз коли наші хлопці ідуть в
наступ на жаль вони збільшеє стає
поранени героїв війна вона така як вона
і є вона важка жорстока зараз для
закладу і всього регіону каже директор
важливо забезпечити реабілітаційні
ресурси аби відновлювати захисників тут
у Дніпрі відповідне відділення дозволило
би повністю ставити на ноги більше
тисячі бійців на рік турникетов нигде не